Ziploc bags fantastic product but
unfortunately they're not
one-size-fits-all, especially if you have
little gizmos gadgets or small trinket
that you're trying to package up so much
bag for so little items so for this
video I'm going to show you how you can
modify your Ziploc bags to be any size
or shape you want. not sponsored by
Ziploc but I wish it was.
now one quart freezer bags like these
are made of polyethylene which is a
lightweight plastic polymer and it can
be melted which means if we took
something long thin and made of metal
like these old metal coat hangers we
should see theoretically be able to heat
them up and cut our bags in half now if
you're wondering where you can even get
these metal coat hangers anymore just
try stopping by your local dry cleaners
they'll probably give them to you for free if
not four for a buck now we're also going
to need some kind of a cloth or a towel
and you're going to want one that is not
super meaningful to you because it's
going to get scorched it's going to get
burned and it's probably gonna get
covered in plastic as well I'm using one
of these shop rags and its purpose is
just to provide a little bit of cushion
now what we want to do with our rag is
set it down on the counter and fold it
up into thirds and this is just going to
build up the height a little bit so it
provides a little more cushion next we
want to take our ziplock bag and lay it
down onto the rag in the direction we
want to make the cut now this is the
part where things start heating up a
little bit so it's a good idea to have
some protective gloves maybe some safety
glasses if you're into that and for a
heat source we're going to be using
either a BBQ igniter or if you have one
a propane torch works great as well you
can also use the open flame from a gas
range as well if you've got one of those
in any case we just need some kind of a
hot open flame that we can concentrate
on the bottom of our wire
okay so our wire is heated up now we're
just going to drop it by the top line it
over our bag and press it straight down
we can hold that in place grab the
corner of our bag and just peel it right
up and as easy as that we now have a
customized ziploc bag check that out
look how clean the edges are as well
it's absolutely beautiful actually
worked out better than I thought and
because we're using metal as it heats-up
it will have a tendency sometimes to
bend upward so it's not a bad idea just
to bend it down and heat up first
because then when you compress it will
press down into the material rather than
having an awkward middle part that
doesn't get touch at all
when it's smoking
you know it's ready
beautiful comes off just like chicken
strips alright so here we are guys we
just did four cuts we turn one ziplock
bag into five different strips and
here's the coolest thing about them
these are 1-inch strips you can see the
edges are still very very clean and a
cool thing is there's still watertight
as well which means you can still fill these things up with juice and put them in the
freezer and make your own frizzy pop how
cool is that
not only can you use this trick to make
custom frizzy pops which is awesome but
you could use it to make travel-sized
toiletries as well figure out this throw
a little shampoo a little bit of lotion
maybe some mouthwash in a bag you can
seal it off completely so there's not
even any Ziploc at all it's just
completely sealed and watertight
now this trick doesn't work just for
making popsicles it works really well
for sorting and organizing for example
you can make little pouches to help
organize your sets of screws or to make
a little trial packets of samples you
want to send to people in the mail we
also found that if you heat up the
bottom of the hanger and press it into
the plastics but pull it away before it
has a chance to melt through it weld the
two sides of the bag together and
creates little compartments in the same
bag now let's stop and take just a
second to talk about what happened first
of all we discovered today that sandwich
bags are made of polyethylene the heat
sensitive plastic and by heating up
something like a metal coat hanger we
could almost use it as a heat knife to
cut a ziplock bag into custom shapes and
sizes we found that by cutting up one
bag into different strips we can fill
each of those strips up with juice and
freeze them to make improvised frizzy
pops we found that by heat treating the
top once again we could permanently seal
all the liquid inside next we tried
cutting out a couple of small pouches
for organizing small trinkets and
gadgets and we filled up other small
bags that can be used for storage or
samples and by pressing a hot hanger to
the bag but pulling away before it
melted through we found that we could
create different compartments in one
single bag so there you have it guys the
shapes sizes and functions you can pull
from a sandwich bag are now is unlimited
as your imagination thanks for joining
for this experiment today I'll be
looking for you the next one talk to you
then it just peels right off, oops that slipped
looks like my coat hanger was a
little bit bent the wrong way